so Marvel Comics has this ridiculously
overpowered character named Clyde
wincham check this out so there's this
story where basically Clyde is this guy
in an alternate reality which is
essentially the Marvel Comics version of
the real world he's
that has powers and he can alter reality
on a universal scale so this guy
accidentally resurrects his dad from the
dead his mom freaks out cracks him over
the head with a Candlestick and he's
confined to a hospital for the mentally
disabled the only thing he has to keep
him company are his Comics but the
nurses decide to be dicks and they take
him away so ultimately this guy freaks
out loses his [ __ ] he ends up snatching
up all the different superheroes and
super powered beings from Marvel Comics
and brings him into the real world
Galactus Captain America the whole nine
yards this great big huge conflict
ensues the world's about to be destroyed
by Galactus and then ultimately Clyde
wincham ends up sending them all back
the craziest thing about this this isn't
even the most powerful thing that he'll
ever do in Marvel Comics make sure you
click the link in the description for
the full story